comme vous le savez hier
calé
mais qu'a eu 200 y et non pas qu'elle
aille on pourrait croire
qu'elle aille à chanter sur j'ai encore
rêvé d'elle oui il y à chanter elle
était en combinaison de feu où elle
était magnifique
les comédiens après cette prestation
une chose dramatique a eu lieu horrible
ouais s'est passé quelque chose de très
grave
et il y a
un coupable
ici
autour de la table ça ne peut pas être
jean michel denis bernard montiel
puisqu'ils n'étaient pas là en revanche
tous les autres
à peut-être jean-luc
peut-être agathe isabelle fils maxime ou
encore ludivine ou benjamin castaldi
benjamin castaldi tiens parlons-en
benjamin castaldi il a débarqué en
france en 1954 à bord d'une renault 18
il fait le malin sur les grands
boulevards à paris puis de fil en
aiguille petit larcin cambriolage il
prend pour 25 ans tony dans le loft
bouyer des mots très grave ont été
prononcées hier
très très grave je vais vous montrer ce
qui s'est passé je vous laisse découvrir
la vidéo
regarde
nous sommes le 18 décembre 2010 est sur
le plateau de thé pmp l'ambiance est à
son comble le chanteur richard de witte
et sur scène pour interpréter son tube
j'ai encore rêvé d'elle et il était
accompagné par la belle kelly v de v
line
alors que le public acclame la
prestation des deux artistes
un drame va avoir lieu en effet se
laisse emporter par la tenue sexy de
kelly une personne autour de la table va
commettre l'irréparable en prononçant
une phrase qui va casser la magie qui a
prononcé cette phrase
quel en était le but kelly avait-elle
ainsi jolies boules pour mériter cette
formule
autant de questions auxquelles
l'inspecteur baba va essayer de répondre
qui a dit l affaire du beau qu hier
kelly a chanté il ya quelqu'un qui a du
beau cul j'aime beaucoup je sais
désormais quelques coupes à leur trafic
était coupable
qui a dit ça benjamin cas n'a jamais
jamais oui oui benjamin castaldi oui
saga bourne jamais jamais de la vie
c'est pas vous tient vraiment à l'or lui
vraiment ne connaît pas mal vite c'est
mon genre jamais de la vie je sais le
mieux un peu de tout maxime kenny ce
mois d'août chez moi je pense que c'est
pas demain ça peut pas être maxime non
sap et pas de taxis ouais ça me choque
un peu enfin je vous comprends je vais
vous dire un au luc a dit ça pour paul
plénière mais qu'on croit
ouais voilà donc tiennent donc
oui oui oui durable aura des sanctions
contre dave comportera des
sables-d'olonne certitude quoi ça on a
peut plus avoir aucune certitude
non merci pour votre concours dont vous
étiez là